good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy wednesday we had
one thing for you now we have another
because things aren't
changing enough in this country or
changing fast enough we begin tonight
with the fox news alert
we just learned the democrats in the
congress are preparing a bill to pack
the supreme court to add
four new justices to our supreme court
that would change the country forever
now we're going to be monitoring this
and bringing more details as we get them
but as of right now we know these things
the bill is being led by congressman
jerry nadler of new york that's in the
house
and in the senate by senator ed markey
of massachusetts
again packing the supreme court you
remember
president biden said he was impaneling
some kind of blue ribbon commission to
consider this
now elected democrats in the congress
are trying to force it
joining us now to react is judge jeanine
pirro she's the host of justice with
judge janine josh thanks so much
for joining us tonight so packing the
supreme court this is something that
franklin roosevelt tried
had to back off because it was it was
considered too radical in the middle of
the most radical legislative
period in american history the new deal
this was too much
what would this mean if it were to
happen
what this would mean tucker is that we
would have another legislative body
uh in the united states congress has
historically
uh been filled up the supreme court has
historically been
filled by presidents who when they are
there if there's a vacancy they appoint
someone in line with their thinking
so sometimes they're more liberal
sometimes they're more conservative
and i think that when president trump
had the ability the
ability to add three justices the left
went crazy
now biden wouldn't answer if you'll
recall the question
during the uh during the campaign and
neither would kamala harris answer
and now they just had a committee that
was supposed to look at it
now all of a sudden they've got a bill
uh that the house they've got support in
the house and in the senate
this will change the united states
dramatically
the left will have the ability to have a
court which is essentially nothing more
than a legislative leaning
uh body that will approve of all of the
issues that they are trying to make
across the board in the united states
we will no longer have a supreme court
that is based on the number of justices
depending upon who the president is and
it will all be leaning toward the person
who is in
office and who has the power this is
madness it's
madness as if the country isn't lost
enough
i i wonder if it just by
this happening the country doesn't
change i mean
so people imagine the supreme court or
third branch of government
is essentially impartial i mean these
are wise people with lifetime
appointments whose only job is to assess
legislation against the constitution
and decide whether it's consistent with
that the democrats are now saying
no more pretense it's purely a political
body rubber stamps our agenda i mean
won't this change how people feel about
that
well it'll change what people feel about
the court but that won't make a darn bit
of difference to the people who are in
power
who are determined to make sure that
their agenda is passed
because you've got the president and
you've got the uh you've got the
congress
and now you've got the supreme court i
mean look you can look at
amendments to the constitution and
decide that there are issues that really
spin off of that amendment
when you have activists on the supreme
court they can take issues that we never
considered constitutional issues and
make them the law of the land
this is lunacy whether it has to do
with unions or criminal justice or
whatever their agenda is for the day
there is no longer an objective body
that the united states can respect
the supreme court of the land they will
we will lose our respect for that court
is nothing more than a political
con political legislative body an
imprimatur if you will
for the democrats i think that's wise
and i think your first observation is
every bit is wise which is they don't
care what you think
this is which is not the way we think of
democracy in a democracy our leaders
care what we think by definition
judging i appreciate it so much thank
you
thank you